It is my great pleasure to introduce
you guys to the USA for UN HCR.
This is a group that has
supported refugees through
their partnerships with uh,
you went high council on refugees and
the partners of the UN High Council and
refugees.
They work diligently to provide support,
food,
shelter,
water safety and protection
to displace people.
And to tell you a little bit more
about the group and project hive,
which by the way was one of fast
company's 2017 most innovative companies.
So we are in,
we are in store for a treat today.
Um, without any further
ado, she only, she coulda,
who is the major gifts manager
for USA for you. And HCR.
Thank you so much for having us here
today. We're really excited to be here,
especially given Google's partnership,
which we'll talk about in a moment. Um,
but I just wanted to let you know,
first off,
of course we have a Hashtag,
um,
and that's Google talk refugees and you
can find us on Twitter at UN refugee
agency. So if you feel so inclined,
please do give us a shout out online.
Um, so we're going to be talking about the
global refugee crisis, um, to start out.
And then I'm going to talk about the
work of the UN refugee agency and USA for
you and HCR. And this is going to be
followed by a presentation of the hive,
which is a special projects unit of USA
for you and HCR and what they're doing
to unlock a larger American audience
to further the work that we do. Um,
and then my colleague Nick is going to
talk about Google's partnership and then
we'll also have time at
the end for questions.
So just to start off, I don't know
if you've heard the latest numbers,
but over 67 million people have
been displaced because a of,
of violence,
conflict and persecution,
this is an unprecedented
level of global displacement,
the largest since World War II.
Yeah.
Um, and just to give you a sense
of the scale of the crisis,
24 people around the world
are displaced every minute,
which means by the time we're done
with this 45 minute presentation,
about a thousand people would have been
forced to leave home. Um, and of course,
behind all of these numbers are countless
stories of hardship, grief and loss,
and just the struggle to rebuild lives.
So these 67 million refugees
and internally displaced
people mainly come from 15
active refugee emergencies. And here
you can see that on the map. Um,
I'm sure a lot of you have heard
about the Syrian refugee crisis,
so I'm not going to get too into
it, especially given Google's, um,
work on the searching for Stereo website,
which if you haven't checked it out,
I highly recommend it.
Um,
but there are 5 million refugees who
have been forced to leave Syria and 6
million still displaced
within the country. Um,
but today I'm going to talk about two
other refugee emergencies that aren't
featured as prominently in the news.
And the first one, it's South Sudan.
So since December of 2013,
civil war has claimed the
lives of thousands of people.
It's driven over 1.5
million refugees from,
from the country and 1.9 within,
um, in 2016, so last year,
an average of 3000 people crossed South
Sudan's borders in one day and 67% of
these refugees are children.
So a combination of ongoing conflict,
violence and trout have deprived the
farmers have the ability to grow and
produce food.
And this is creating a manmade famine,
100,000 people or an immediate danger
of death by starvation and underserved
neighboring countries like the DRC,
Uganda and Ethiopia are hosting these
refugees at an unsustainable rate.
And this is creating Africa's
largest scale refugee crisis.
Okay.
Um,
another often overshadowed crisis is
what's happening in the northern triangle
of Central America right now. And
those countries consist of El Salvador,
Honduras,
and Guatemala.
And we're seeing a dramatic escalation
in violence by organized criminal gangs.
And as a result,
the number of refugees have increased
from 20 1020 12 to 146,020 16 and those
numbers may not seem that large,
but the fact that it's escalating so
quickly is a growing cause of concern.
We're seeing increases in disappearances
forced recruitment into gangs,
extortion,
and sexual violence.
And among these growing numbers of
refugees are women and girls and
unaccompanied and separated children,
and they're particularly vulnerable
to protection risks such as human
trafficking and sexual assaults.
So what does the UN refugee agency do?
So UNH CR is the world's
leading organization with
a mandate by the UN to aid
and protect those who have
been forced to flee home.
So there are about 11,000 UNHC
our employees and 128 countries.
Um,
and 90% of them are in the fields and
often remote and dangerous locations.
And when an emergency strikes UNHC
archi mobilize aid within 72 hours.
And they've also helped over 50 million
refugees successfully restart their
lives since 1950.
So you're a quick chart of what
you and HCR does.
So the agency provides life
saving assistance like shelter,
food,
water safety,
but it also provides critical resources
that are necessary to rebuild lives.
So cash assistance programs,
education,
job in skills training.
Um, USA for you in HCR is
the UN refugee agencies,
national partner in the U S so we work
on raising awareness and funds to further
UNHCRs work. So we provide
help, hope and home.
So help in the way of
life saving assistance,
hope in the form of job skills
training and ultimately home,
whether it's in their original country
or in a different country like the u s
and this is just how UNHCRs finance.
So if you take a look at this
green segment right here,
this is where USA for
you and HCR comes in.
So we're one of the two
largest contributors of
private sector funding and our
donors give anywhere from $30 to $3
million to further the mission of the UN
HCR.
And given the refugee crisis that I just
described and also the uncertainty of
the rest of the pie, we're really
focused on growing the segment even more.
And Erin done from the hive is going to
talk about one of the ways that we do
just that.
Okay.
Thank you.
Shyanne um,
definitely having that background to
understand the crisis is really important.
Um, but today I'm going to talk a little
bit more specifically about the United
States and how we can really start to
support the refugee crisis more. Um,
so to start,
I'm going to ask you guys all a question.
What percent of the US public do you
guys think donate to humanitarian causes?
60%. Anybody else? 20%.
2% 2%. Ooh, anybody else? Well, 2%.
It was probably the closest. Um, and
some of you guys might be surprised.
Only 6% of, uh, of, of the
American public donate team,
Ma humanitarian causes.
Um,
even for somebody like me that's been
working in this space for years was pretty
shocked by that number.
But when we started to look closer
at the number we discovered,
there's probably a reason for this.
And a lot of it is because all the big
NGOs like us and other ones like UNICEF
and save the children,
we're all competing after that same 6%
because we know that those people are
ripe and ready to take action.
So we want it to look at how do we
expand that 6% how do we go out to these
people that aren't,
aren't engaged at all in humanitarian
causes and try to get them to activate.
We knew it wasn't going to just be
throwing more money at more advertising
targeting that same percent. We needed
real data science and innovation.
Hm.
So UNHCRs started asking
these three main questions.
Now you and HCR is pretty.
Um,
it's pretty good when it
comes to marketing in Europe
and other markets and they
have a really strong support there.
But as we all know,
the United States is a
totally different ballgame.
So we had to approach it differently.
So in 2014,
UNHC are and USA from
Unh cr called the hive,
which is a special project
trying to unlock a larger
audience here in the United
States.
We set up the hive here in New York
and we hired some of the brightest and
smartest people from
different backgrounds,
from politics or from the private sector.
We wanted everybody that could look at
this problem in a completely different
way.
And when we first started the hive,
we did a lot of testing and yes,
we failed a few times,
but a lot of times we found out
some pretty awesome stuff. Um,
a few of which we'll go
over a little bit later. Um,
but the hive was really set up
to have data as our backbone. Um,
so we built a data model and we use
that to infuse into a number of our
campaigns so we could
reach beyond that 6%.
Now our strategy has changed a little
bit over time. When we first started,
nobody was talking about
the refugee crisis.
So our goal was just to get people
in the u s to start talking more.
But in 2015, as you guys
may know, things changed,
the crisis hit Europe and a little
boy washed up on a beach and suddenly
everybody was talking about refugees.
Things have shifted even more,
as more terrorist attacks have hit Europe.
And often that conversation
sadly goes towards refugees.
So instead of just getting
people to talk about refugees,
we're trying to change the conversation,
we're trying to close that otherness
gap and help Americans relate more to
refugees because after all,
they're just like us.
So the hive is powered by data science,
innovative technology,
creative campaigns and
strategic partnerships. Oh.
And uh,
this year we were recently featured as
one of fast company's most innovative
NGOs.
And as I mentioned earlier,
the backbone of this operation
is really on data science.
So I'm going to hand it off to my
colleague Rita Co who heads up our data
strategy.
Thank you Erin. Um, it's such a
pleasure to be here today guys.
Thank you for taking time out of
your day. Uh, so data science,
I feel like it's a new coin term that's
been tossed around a lot as of late. Um,
and it involves a lot of
different professionals,
whether that be someone in
statistics, computer science, uh,
someone like myself. That's why on the
analyst side and taking the numbers.
So what does that all mean?
Um,
and how did the hive take that and
apply it to the refugee crisis? Uh,
so Aaron Hussein,
we built a data model.
This model essentially allowed us to
target about 250 million Americans out of
the 320 million in the United States.
And it gave us a more complete and
kind of holistic understanding, uh,
of an individual.
And so now we were being,
we were able to see beyond just
the demographic variables of age,
gender, income and so forth. But we were
able to see more of their attitudes,
their purchasing behaviors, and
we were able to see, you know,
whether they would have an affinity to
engage in the global refugee crisis and
support our efforts.
So what is predictive modeling?
Um, I'm sure this concept is,
is certainly not a new one for
the folks in the room today.
It's essentially the process of
taking data and defining and creating
predictions of throughout the behavior.
In our case that the UN refugee agency,
the desired behavior is obviously someone
that's going to support our efforts in
addressing the refugee crisis.
Whether that be through donations,
whether that be through
awareness and advocacy.
And so what we did was we took a that
desired response and we created that as
our target variable. We said
we would like, you know,
John Doe who lives in California to engage
in the refugee crisis and everything
about John Doe, whether that
be his age, gender, income,
a household where he lives,
all that becomes the predictors.
Um, and from the target
variable and the predictors,
we ran statistical algorithms to
determine the association between the two.
And then from that,
we're able to see individually on a tour
of the 250 million Americans how they
were likely to engage if serve the
right messaging on the right platform.
Okay.
So how did we build this predictive model?
Uh,
we ran two national surveys and I've
persuasion online persuasion test,
um, and these, uh,
in the next few slides I'll go over how
we build these predictive models. Um,
essentially this allowed us to
gauge those that are highly aware,
highly supportive, and
highly knowledgeable of the
crisis in the United States.
So the national survey was around in July,
2015 and not surprisingly,
over 70% had never heard of
us. Um, which is, um, a result,
which I'm sure maybe even yourselves
have not heard of us until today. Um,
but interestingly six and 10 of
them supported our efforts and,
and giving these life saving
assistance services, uh,
to refugees in those first forcibly
displaced. So our brand was,
was not very high. We also ran
an online persuasion test. And,
uh, from those messages, message frames,
we were able to tell and Gardner where
the support was in the United States for
the UN refugee agency and our efforts.
One message that garnered support
on increasing economic aid,
uh,
was the message about over half of the
refugees are children under the age of
17. And to give you a scale
of the sense of that, if,
as Sean was saying earlier,
65,
so 67 million people exist today globally
who have been forcibly displaced.
Now imagine 65 million, put that in
half. That's around 32, 33 million.
And that is essentially the
population of Canada. So take Canada,
make them all under the age of 17,
and say that is the size of the population
of children that are now forcibly
displaced.
So that is what moved Americans
into a supporting economic aid,
uh, for refugees, which
is compelling message.
Another message that had an effect on
accepting more refugees was the fact that
refugees shape, uh, America,
including Albert Einstein.
And so one of my,
I guess favorite examples,
I have a refugee that's made some
huge differences in the world.
So we ran this message test,
we ran these surveys and we
have all this survey data.
How did we use this data to build the
models while we first we took all the
respondents and we upended the
demographic information. Uh,
so you can see on the table here,
you know,
we have or different scoring and we
were able to append a lots of variables.
This is only gender Asian income.
So it's not a true example of the sheer
amount of data that we had available to
us.
And we essentially took all that data
from the survey respondents and we narrow
the variables using a statistical method
called Lasso in order to determine
which, which of those variables
were the most predictive.
After that we ran a logistic regressions
and from there then we cross validated
the model to make sure that it didn't,
uh,
over fit and at generalized
across different samples.
And then from there we were able to
see those that were highly supportive,
highly knowledgeable,
the crisis,
highly aware and those that had
a willingness to be contacted.
So from from there we were able then to
pend a scores to each of the individuals
on our file, which is
about 250 million. Um,
you'll see from this fictitious
supporter here, uh, Joe,
he will have had all of his demographic
information, but in addition to that,
the five scores, um, and so
support obviously for the crisis,
eight would a high score, obviously
being a high probability, um,
and then a look alike would be someone
that looks like our current donor and is
likely to make a donation
and support our efforts.
So if you can imagine,
then we have this,
this model that it has a predictive
score for each of these individual
Americans.
And now we're able to see on a micro
level how to engage a different audiences
in the United States.
So we stacked these models on top of
each other and we ended up with five a
target populations. Uh, the,
the first one being the lookalikes
and that's 49 million individuals.
So those are 49 million out of the
320 that likely I donate to that,
to USA for your niche cr.
And then we have who we call
the persuadables and those
are the core supporters,
education and brand recognition.
And those comprise about
14 million individuals.
Now going back to what
Erin was saying on the 6%,
that is certainly growing
that red segment. Uh,
we are now approximately
out a million supporters.
So that's 14 times more than a,
where we are now today.
So it provides us a good testing ground
of microtargeting in a political Salway
on these 14 million. And these
are people that are new audiences,
so they aren't, you know, if they
are their prime to be engaged,
but they are not yet I donating
and supporting our efforts.
And then of course not surprisingly 173
million over half of the United States
population or are non targets. So you
know, they don't look like our modeling.
They're not likely to support our efforts.
So after stacking these models,
you can also see then on an individual
level what it would look like across the
United States.
And we're able to then to see on a map
geographically how to engage each of
these supporters.
Um,
and so what we've essentially done with
this predictive model is we've married
that the products people buy,
the brands they trust and their propensity
and likelihood to engage in a social
issue like the refugee crisis.
And we're able then to do political
style microtargeting married with our
predictive modeling.
So I'm going to hand it over back to Erin
to discuss how we take this data on a
micro level and aggregate, uh,
into our campaigning. Oh, sorry.
I'll take your question in the back,
the first slide with
the individual straps,
those are just examples of
where those things you actually,
those are just examples where that
would show would probably be, you know,
if they've subscribed to like wellness
health, um, uh, into that level unless,
you know, we're able to receive
the letter from bon appetit.
We weren't able to come from that.
So, um, thank you for the question.
Okay.
A hand it over.
And Aaron,
thank you Rita. So I'm going to
talk about how we take that. Um,
can we take all that data and all that
learnings that we absorbed and we turned
it into campaigns to try to grow that 6%.
So,
so far we've run 22 micro campaigns,
all of these with a different
audience and a different goal. Um,
and all of our campaigns
follow this same framework. Um,
Rita kind of talked about
the first part of it,
which is modeling the data
to find the right audience,
to find the right people within that
persuadable buckets. The next part,
which is just as important, is finding
the right context and messaging.
And the right call to action.
So as we all know,
there's so many different Americans and
we fall into so many different kinds of
audiences that it really matters.
It really mattered for us to find that
right and call to action to get that
conversion. So for example, to the
campaigns I'm about to talk about,
one is for an LGBT audience while one
is for a more Christian conservative
audience. So they both obviously had to
have a little bit different messaging.
Okay.
The first one, which is one of my personal
favorites is called rainbow refugees.
Um,
and we decided to do this campaign because
we really saw an opportunity within
the LGBT AI audience because
they're already hyper political,
very active, and they've accomplished
quite a bit in the last 20 years.
So we thought maybe this audience
could also help us move the refugee
conversation.
And at the same time they're having
to be a major LGBTA refugee crisis,
which few people are talking
about, especially in the media, um,
because it doesn't fall into
the Syria, um, storyline. Um,
but right now there's 77
countries where it's illegal. Uh,
world homosexuality is illegal.
So there's men and women that are fleeing
for their lives looking for safety
just because of who they love.
So we paired that messaging and
that issue with the LGBT audience.
And so far we've seen a
huge uptick in engagement.
One of the tools that we often kind
of tried to use was pop culture.
Instead of trying to get people from
all these different backgrounds to come
talk to us about refugees,
we tried to go where they were
already having conversations online,
whether it was the grammys or
in this case, the world series.
So two years ago during the world series,
we took a look at some of our big numbers
and some of the big numbers happening
around baseball. And we quickly found
something that was pretty unique.
So the amount of people that flee on
a daily basis at this time was 42,000
people, which is the same size or
relatively close to the same size,
is a lot of the baseball stadiums in the
United States. So we took some of the,
we took some of the teams that were still
in the playoffs and we modeled up some
of these social media memes.
I'm trying to depict the idea of sitting
in that stadium and thinking about that
whole stadium,
having to flee that day.
And the really cool thing that we got out
of this was that we were able to reach
a younger male audience,
which for any NGO is pretty incredible.
Our typical donor,
like many NGOs is older women.
So to be able to reach that
audience was pretty exciting for us.
Okay.
Another tool that we often tested and
tried with some of our campaigns was doing
unbranded.
Many studies show that Americans are more
likely to support a cause rather than
a brand x,
especially if that brand has the UN in it.
So one of the campaigns that we ran
that was unbranded was called under his
wings. We built a community
targeting Christian conservatives,
Catholics and tried to use messaging
that was more relatable to them. Um,
we also tried to use the opportunity,
the pope coming to town, uh,
as another opportunity to reach out to
this audience. So we ran a campaign, uh,
which was, Jesus was a refugee,
uh, which was free bumper stickers.
And we ran this full
page ad over here in the,
in USA today when the pope
came to visit. Um, and we got,
we had a lot of interest in, a lot of
people signed up for the free stickers,
even some people that didn't
quite fall into that audience.
But we're excited for a bumper sticker
beyond just campaigns.
We also have been building some digital
tools and different products the first
time, first test into the product
world. We dead refugee emojis. Um,
so this is the keyboard that we
built with a partner and so far we,
so far it's been able to help us kind
of have a new way of engaging a younger
millennial audience.
Um,
and it's also been helping us with
some of our data science currently.
There's a lot of studies
going into sentiment and,
and being able to kind of look at social
media and get sentiment scores based on
emojis. So this has been helpful as
we kind of look further into that.
And last but not least,
we are working currently
on launching a new product.
I'm using Facebook Messenger's
new BOT technology.
We're working with a special
partner to slowly a scale up,
a new product that would allow users
to have a more intimate and meaningful
engagement with a refugee like character.
Um,
so this will allow people to kind of have
a one on one experience with a refugee
and in a way walk a mile in their shoes.
Um,
so we are launching our Beta version, uh,
next week, uh, with World Refugee Day.
If you guys didn't know World
Refugee Day is June 20th,
so if you go onto our Facebook next
week and you chat up our chat messenger,
um, you can go through the experience.
Um, but just to warn you that it's very,
uh, it's just our Beta, so
we are still testing. Um,
and you can definitely expect more if
you watch this space. So with that,
I'm going to turn it over
to my colleague Nick,
who oversees our corporate partnerships
and he's going to talk about the amazing
support of Google and how you
guys can get involved more.
Alright, thanks Erin. And
thanks to everybody who's a,
again taking time out of
your busy work day. And, um,
I know we've had an opportunity
to talk a little bit about, uh,
the great needs that UNHCRs facing
the work that unit chairs undertaking.
Obviously the unique and
innovative work of the hive.
But I really wanted to talk about the
great work that Google is doing and has
been doing since we began
partnering with Google in 2015.
So just for some context, um, since 2015,
Google as an institution has provided
over three point $8 million in critical
funding, uh, for UNHCRS programs. Um,
in some cases specifically focused on
the Syria response in the surrounding
region, countries such as Jordan and
Lebanon. And even more importantly,
a Google is contributed some loosely
earmarked funds for UNHCRs general
emergency response.
I knew that Syria is often been
driving a lot of our talking points,
but there's a global refugee crisis
that continues to unfold and as we again
have highlighted, the needs
are tremendous. So, uh,
Google support has been truly remarkable.
One of the interesting things
about our partnership with Google,
it's not certainly at all limited to
fundraising and it's actually a really
dynamic,
multifaceted and global partnership.
And certainly as a corporate
partnerships person, um,
we always an often look beyond just
the cash resources of companies that we
engage with, but to look to
their expertise, to look to
the capacity to really, um,
you know,
advance amplify our work.
I think one really great example
is the searching for Syria.
A micro site that I know has
been mentioned in many ways,
we're trying to reengage the u s
public in a very different manner.
And the searching for serious
site has allowed us to humanize,
to sh show exactly what life is like for
people living in these really difficult
conditions. Um, certainly the mirroring
of Syria before and after the war is,
it's really remarkable.
It's really relatable to
Americans because in many ways,
a serious life before the war looked
similar in some respects to those in,
in the United States. So, um, again,
a big thank you for Google's
collaboration on that.
And I wanted to talk a little bit about
Google's most recent employee engagement
program and say a big huge thank
you to everybody in the room. Um,
even if you haven't participated,
um,
you're a valuable employee
voice on behalf of refugees. Um,
today that campaign raised $440,000 for
USA for you and HCR and I've included
just some bullets on what that
is equivalent to an UNHCRs,
a programmatic universe.
I'm,
one of the things that really sticks
out to me as somebody who's been working
around the UN refugee agency for awhile
is that your support is equivalent to
nearly 10,000 Syrian refugee children
gaining access to education. Um, again,
back to the Syria narrative. I
know if you saw on the news, um,
but there's often a lost
generation that's referred to, um,
with kids being out of school in some
cases up to five, six, seven years.
So for children to gain access back
to education, to regain normalcy,
to um,
be able to continue their education like
any other child should be able to, um,
is hugely important.
And we'll have a long term transformative
effect on those children's lives.
So I really wanted to call
that one out in particular
and beyond just the thank you,
um,
which I think if anything else you take
away from my portion of the conversation
is, again, thank you. Um,
is just some additional ways that you as
Google employees can continue to help.
Um, no, we've talked about searching for
Syria. If you haven't already done so,
please do share with any of
your friends, colleagues, um,
because they can become valuable allies
overall for UNHCRs work in the US.
Um, continue to please to
commit to a workplace giving.
I know that there's a variety
of institutions that, um,
you can choose to support and we've been
fortunate enough to be chosen by Google
employees at,
it's such a wonderful level and it will
be talked about and Aaron's presentation
World Refugee Day is next week.
Come June 20th.
Please follow us on social media.
Uh, please amplify our messaging.
It's really awesome to have, um, again,
an audience with you guys in touch.
Good timing. So we can't
highlight that. Um,
please visit our website and there
is a URL URL here. Excuse me.
They can direct you to some additional
ideas of how you could even involve your
communities and a fundraising awareness
activities. And again, lastly,
please continue to follow
us on social media.
And with that I'll just skip over to the
last line and open it up for questions.
Please use the microphone.
You have to have a 20% projects
that Googlers good, participated.
I'm sorry I couldn't hear
that very well. So, uh,
at Google we have the possibility of
spending some of our time either volunteer
or as it's called 20% time.
Do you have any projects we can help with?
Yup. Um, so Rita and I, uh,
we can definitely take that because the
hive is always interested in working, um,
especially with people in
the technology sector. Um,
so definitely I can give you
our cards afterwards. Um,
we'd love to hear kind of what your
background is. We kind of have our,
our wishlist of things that we'd
like to do and want to do. Um,
so usually we can kind of take,
um,
what your background is and try to mirror
it with one of those projects. But yes,
thank you.
We would be extremely happy for that.
Yeah. And um, we also have, um,
internal website where people can,
uh, different nonprofits can put a
bunch of volunteer opportunities and a,
you can write down a set of skills and
all the rest and then after that, yeah,
all the company will have access to it.
So.
Great.
And if I could just add to Erin's comment,
we are constantly looking
for data scientists that or
those that you don't call
yourself a data scientist so you could
have the skills or data scientists that I
can look at our data sets and assist us.
Um,
I'm just going to hand
the mic over to Kevin.
I'm just going to say
there is no official, a 20%
engagement in place right now,
but that doesn't mean that you can't
engage sort of outside of the typical
Google engagement model. Sure. But I do
know we have a volunteer site, which is,
which is not specifically
20%, but like exactly. Yup.
Got It. Cool. Thank you. Um, yeah.
When you did your analysis,
um,
was there anything that jumped out at
you that was something you didn't expect,
um, when you were kind of
looking at demographics?
Yeah, that's a great. Um,
I think, you know, to pinpoint one,
one finding i's hard and in that,
um,
sometimes actually the most obvious
finding is very illuminating because we
assume, as Erin was describing
earlier with a lot of the, uh,
individuals that engage in social classes
and donate in the United States are,
are women liberal leaning,
um,
well specifically to our cause I given
the refugee crisis and where it stands
politically. Um, so with that said,
it's even illuminating to see that who
we think are our look alike are indeed
who sign up and engage
on these micro tests. Um,
so in that is a validation
in itself. Um, you know,
sometimes we'll have moments where I
will run a test and we'll be like, well,
that's Kinda interesting, weird outlier.
But, um, at this moment in time,
I can't think of a
specific, but I would, um,
there's certainly nothing that at this
moment we're able to scale and apply to
the larger United States population.
So you mentioned that about 6% of
Americans donee devotee statistics of how
successfully hive has been able to like
expand that donor pool or how effective
the target of a campaigning has been.
Okay.
Um,
I would kind of say it that we,
we just kinda started to lay this
groundwork to really scale it up. Um,
so I don't think we have any numbers
specifically around that 6%. Um,
definitely there's been
an uptick in donations,
especially to refugee
organizations recently, um,
with certain things that have
been happening in the news. Um,
so that has been in a way helpful. Um,
but we are really trying to kind of,
um, you know, a lot of what we did in the
beginning was a lot of that testing. Um,
so because there was
like 22 micro campaigns,
now we kind of have an idea
of where to go next. Um,
we're obviously not going to run 22 more.
Uh,
we might just do one to three that
are much bigger and scale them. Um,
but I also think regard
laying this groundwork, um,
with the backbone of data science
that can also be applied to other
organizations. Um, so we are
also talking with other NGOs, um,
and trying to kind of, um, make it a more,
a more cultural shifts similar in the
way that the Obama campaign really forced
political campaigns to make a total shift.
Great question.
Um,
one more about the refugee bought.
Why,
why did you decide to do that?
When there's like what seems like a
surplus of actual refugees that could kind
of be in these chat sessions
you're trying to promote?
Sure. Um, so there are kind
of, uh, there's two things
that are kind of happening.
We do have UNHC our global,
which is in Geneva and they have an
innovation team whose mandate is more, um,
working directly on products that
support and help refugees. Um,
I can't speak to it too much,
but I do know that there some things in
the works to kind of build a Facebook,
a similar Facebook Bot that is more
actually helping directly refugees.
So if they have a question,
um,
using AI will be able to
provide automated responses. Um,
but for our, our mandate
is to really engage, um,
Americans to kind of grow
support. Um, so we are,
we're still in the testing phases of
exactly what we think that we can use. Uh,
Facebook chatbots for, um, and,
and so I think we're you asking why
we're not using actual refugees?
Yeah.
Like instead of having an AI,
why not just connect
people in actual refugees?
A lot of that, a lot of that
does go back to safety. Um,
a lot of times we can't use real
names. We can't give locations. Um,
because a lot of times these people,
um,
are targeted continuously
even after they flee. Um,
so we have a lot of LGBT refugees whose
families even are out to get them.
So we can't, a lot of times they're
reluctant to put their names out there.
On a large scale, um, in
public. Um, but we do,
we do use a lot of their stories and
a lot of their stuff to kind of create
those, um, to create the personas.
Sorry,
just a quick corollary to that because
I think it speaks to a larger issue that
you're perhaps raising is you ACR very
much does engage directly with refugees
and some cases are small level
pilot level, I'd say. Um,
entrepreneurship,
a coding opportunities that are happening
in different locations through the
world beyond just sort of
the refugee response in bots.
There's a lot of other interesting
programs. Um, but yeah, she,
she just knew it offline and I can follow
up more if this sounded interesting.
Um,
so the slightly similar but
response,
um,
you guys showed the sentences that kind
of calls people to donate more unless I
was just wondering if there's a theme
among those like killed inspiration,
like tying it to something
they may be able to relate to,
like what that looked like.
Um,
I should preface that that
survey was conducted on in July,
2015 and so those message frames obviously
have changed dramatically since the
2016 election. Um, and we did
recently random message test. Um,
and we are still in the process
of analyzing those results,
but certainly moral and compassion is,
is a theme that resonates with Americans
and changing behavior and increasing
support. And I'll just hand it over to
Erin and she took a key role in that,
in that pilot.
Yeah.
Yeah. Um, as she said,
we're still kind of analyzing
and going through all that data,
but we did more recently,
a couple months ago,
run a new message test and I think Rita
already kind of hit the nail on the head
that it is moral compassion.
I'm calling on Americans and saying,
America, we're compassionate. We're
giving, let's not turn our backs. Um,
so that kind of messaging we really
saw, um, dead a little bit better.
Any other questions? Okay. Well,
thank you so much. Uh, everyone. Um,
yes, thank you. Um, and obviously if you
guys have any other followup questions,
if you're interested in anything
specific that we talked about,
feel free to follow up.
We brought cards. Um,
we also brought stickers
that say with refugees. Um,
so if you guys want to take some, you
can take multiple given to your friends,
take photos of them, put them on
social media Hashtag with refugees. Um,
and as nick mentioned, World
Refugee Day is, uh, June 20th,
so definitely, um, go online,
sign our petition to stand with
refugees and uh, tell the world
thank you.
Oh,
and back to Kevin or a wonderful hubs.
I was just going to say on the behalf of
everyone here and the employees of the
New York City office, thank you guys for
coming. Thank you for sharing your story.
Um, these guys will be here
for a little bit longer. Um,
that's it.
Thanks.